this is lucy james reading for reviewer
mark delaney this is our finalized
review of dying light 2. so if you've
already seen our review in progress this
is pretty much the same video but with
an added section on the game's online
co-op when developer techland added the
subtitle stay human to dying light 2 it
seemed to signal the team's intentions
to rediscover and showcase the humanity
nestled at the core of the story since
2018 the team has made promises about
the numerous narrative branches dying
like two players would find in the game
those branches are there and they are
indeed plentiful but experiencing them
felt equivalent to falling out of a tree
and hitting my face on every branch on
the way down while dying light's most
crucial element first person parkour is
certainly better than it's ever been in
this sophomore effort much of the rest
of the game fails to keep up
not bad
where's the fish eye
dying like two is set in the fictional
villadore a new city in the story and
features a fresh grizzled hero central
to its conflict as a pilgrim an outsider
perceived as dangerous to the few
remaining safe zones in the world aidan
caldwell ventures into one such hub in
search of his sister mia whom he last
saw years ago through hazy flashbacks
that aren't clear enough for even aiden
to rely on aiden and mia's story is
poorly delivered early and often it
feels as though simply understanding
these two are siblings is meant to be
enough for the player to care about
their hopeful reunion but techland
struggles to show why anyone should be
invested in mia beyond the familial
connection she becomes a living mcguffin
meant to justify aidan's video gamey
escapades as a sidequesting superstar
leaping across tall buildings in a
single bound surrounding aiden is a wide
cast of characters who can sometimes be
diverse and interesting but ultimately
share one thing in common poor voice
acting while agents actor jonah scott
does well and rosario dawson deserves
some credit for her role as his
part-time ally lawan we need to check
the substations ones over there level
with the pk tower what about the fish
eye listen i want to help you and i will
help we'll do this together that's about
it in terms of voice talent other
characters try and fail to pull on
heartstrings in part because of the
subpar acting and the less important the
quest is the worse the acting tends to
be too
everything all right
no
it's grilled the goat is grilled
i'm such an idiot
what happened
i must have over calculated the voltage
see he's useless
i'm sorry
i don't know how i could get it so wrong
it doesn't help that the game's tone
shifts so frequently that players might
experience emotional whiplash when
accepting a wildly silly or deadly
serious character for who they are it's
a constant struggle to feel invested in
what they're asking of aiden because
they so often come off as wooden and
disjointed sure it can be difficult to
account for precisely how a conversation
will be heard in a finished game which
can lead to line delivery issues but
dying light 2 seems to sidestep the
years of progress made in rpgs to
address this particular hurdle much to
every character's detriment there was no
one i cared to spend time with other
than aiden himself because he's nearly
the only character who sounds like a
real person i met one guy who ate a
sausage sandwich and he was fine
he even called it tasty
awesome
thank you thank you thank you dying
light 2's bad story manages to get even
worse by its end when a final act and
frustrating final boss upend any
possibility that there would be
something to salvage by the game's 50th
hour this is a game that was billed as
offering 500 hours of content largely
due to its number of quests and
branching paths but if my job didn't
require it i'd have skipped every
cutscene and dialogue option after the
first hour or so should you decide to
play that way you'll very likely enjoy
your time in villadore more than i did
that's because for all of its story woes
the open world and how you explore it
are genuinely fun first person
platforming is a tricky feat but
techland flexes its muscles and improves
on something that was already very good
after a few upgrades it becomes clear
that aiden is faster and more impressive
than carol crane ever was in the first
game aiden is better equipped too with
sandbox staples like a grappling hook
and glider to further enhance his
travels in some ways this core strength
makes dying light 2 work where so many
other open world games don't rather than
players focusing on the major beats the
main quests and most exciting side
mission and leaving a lot of the
so-called filler untouched here those
peripheral activities represent the
game's finest work parkour time trials
or even just scaling some of the game's
biggest skyscrapers is quality
repeatable fun meanwhile exploring
abandoned stores for valuables while the
undead sleep hunched over like something
out of a horror movie puts the emphasis
on scares in a way i wished there was
more of this is aided by a skill tree
that has very few undesirable perks each
time i could acquire a new skill i had
to pause and really consider what i'd
want
need really next for aiden these skills
are broken into combat and parkour so i
farmed xp pretty reliably just by doing
the things i wanted to do better anyway
armor and gear perks add an additional
role-playing wrinkle that had me feeling
less like a hoarder but rather smarter
for keeping different outfits as builds
for the anti-hero the combat doesn't
shine as brightly as the parkour but
it's not the game's darkest blemish when
faced with hordes of infected including
many new special types such as howlers
that signal a mass of monsters and
anomalies grotesque mini bosses waiting
in arenas at night the combat is at its
best managing a crowd when different
types of monsters are slow or fast
tank-like or agile makes for the good
kind of stress this game was always
meant to have even after 50 hours it's
difficult to control a crowd of zombies
without working up a good sweat in the
process combat with humans most often
the trophy renegades who dress like
legion of doom super fans is less
enjoyable because it regularly comes
down to performing the same small move
set on every crowd of bad guys dodge
slash
there's room for doing some cooler moves
like a vaulting ability that lets you
catapult off one enemy onto another but
rarely is their incentive to be so
stylish i eventually ditched a lot of
this fluff in favor of the dropkick that
sends villains satisfyingly flailing off
of rooftops that one truly never gets
old
stealth mechanics are such an
afterthought that it's hard to
rationalize why they're involved at all
infiltrating enemy bases and taking them
out quietly is the sort of fun far cry
has been driven by for a decade but
dying lights intend to mimic it fails
because there are so few tall grass
areas in the world which is about the
only way to hide from human enemies
dashing across rooftops while the
infected lurk in the streets at night
has a more enjoyable feeling to it but
even then going to street level even for
a moment can prove frustrating because
howlers spot aiden so quickly this
reimagining of the series night cycle
basically turns every touch of the
sidewalk into a run for your life i
found myself wishing for the original
game's vision cones at times at least
that way made a bit more sense from the
player's point of view no matter what
you're doing be it chasing down a story
lead or parkouring for the fun of it or
running for your life the soundtrack
masterfully reacts to every step in a
way i've not seen done in games before
the dynamic music shifts from story to
side mission to open world exploration
without missing a beat even going so far
as to let the air out of the soundtrack
whenever you take a jump helping to give
you that rollercoaster-like sense of
weightlessness
[Applause]
[Music]
strangely enough the music ends up
creating a much stronger sense of
atmosphere and consequences within dying
light too than its story despite all the
time in the figurative oven dying light
2 still feels a bit unpolished too bugs
weren't at the forefront of my bad times
with the game
usually but i witnessed things like
sandbox activities being broken and
issues with the game's geometry where
i'd get stuck on some objects for
reasons i couldn't understand thankfully
a bit of button mashing usually fixed
those hiccups and bugs rarely affected
any of the game's best bits the first
person parkour playing co-op in dying
light 2 does make the experience a bit
more fun bringing friends to activities
like military convoys bandit camps and
gre anomalies makes them all a lot more
manageable and with the exception of the
prologue you can play the entire game in
co-op right down to its lackluster final
boss i've seen my co-op sessions
disconnect several times already which
is frustrating but if there's any saving
grace it's that frequent auto saves mean
i'm not losing much but a few minutes to
reboot the session each time though you
can complete missions side missions and
even earn achievements or trophies in
co-op every box is checked according to
the host's instance of the world i took
weapons and xp back to my own save file
but my map was still disappointingly
full of things i'd already done in co-op
this limitation ultimately leaves me
feeling like co-op is a fun distraction
and best in the end game but not how i'd
play the full experience
if all of this sounds rather
inconsistent it's meant to dying light 2
is a perplexing game it's story and
characters are headache inducing and it
appears to lack polish in many areas but
even a dozen hours after i rolled
credits i found myself going back to the
game to do another parkour challenge
rummage through another abandoned
science lab or just see if i can get
from point a to point b without ever
hitting the ground it's rough around the
edges and it asks players to invest a
lot in its weakest element but once you
realize the story like gravity is only
going to pull you down you can begin to
defy it and enjoy the things dying like
two actually does well
[Music]
inhibitor container detected
inhibitor container nearby